dumbo space.com
für abos s kids und herzlich willkommen
zu einer neuen folge weiter es hat lange
gedauert und ich habe heute den dollar
bei dem hat die richtet cloud
das heißt es recht das waren ihren
weiblichen hat man alle für alle da ist
ja für alle die das format noch nicht
kennen das funktioniert folgendermaßen
wir sind zusammen in einer 64er runde
ist georgi würdig haben und 18 anderen
sammelt er stimmt alter und ideen keine
trudelt wir sind keine ach scheiße man
danke sehr gerne
bitte wir sind in einer 64er runde games
zu zweit eingeräumt ach ich kann ja
nicht nur auf dem übrigens also
aufnehmen im sinne von inventar und wir
spielen gegeneinander er mit fünf
minuten zeit ich bin euch den timer ein
und macht nebenbei noch einmal auf
meiner stoppuhr handy mäßig wisst ihr
bilder nochmal den apfel und eisen hand
weisen
fünf tage später in einer kiste alte ja
ich glaube ich auch nicht
würde jemand klammern also also jetzt
aber was ist falls ihm ist dank bald ja
ja ich hab jetzt grade die stoppuhr
gestartet je nachdem
also ab wo ich gab ihm gesagt habe
da kann man halt wissen in den weg ab
dem zeitpunkt wo ich gesagt hab ja dass
die zeit stoppen laufen fünf minuten
sind den timer sowieso oben rechts
machen wir diesmal mit timer meiner
lieben
und ja die erste ohne das haben wir gut
angekommen deswegen gibt's die zweite
folge leichtes format natürlich finde
ich habe mir auch gedacht man könnte das
mal zu zweit machen eventuell also zwei
gegen zwei
eine coole sache gehabt wenn man in der
64 map so viele kisten hat 66 dir später
sieben schwerter in einer kiste
nein es geht nicht ich war lange bei
neuen kisten schon wieder auf einmal
kommt werden erzählt irgendwas als klaus
ernst gab nicht was
doch amerikanische canto erkenne ich
schon sollte also das waren in den
kisten wir haben eigentlich alle güter
aber irgendwann zwei kisten nicht wieder
drin und da noch die japanische
pianistin diana maximilian übertreibst
ich muss ja lernen ein bisschen mehr
nach hoch warum jetzt lernt was für
training training
was ist los weil ihr okay ich will
wirklich schwerer so friedfertig kennst
ja von mir erzählt dass du dafür bekannt
bist ja eher schneller zu schießen
dazu stehe ich in meinen namen oder ok
also ich würde vielleicht für andere
seite stehen
jeder kann stehen wofür und wann er will
ja ich wollte nur über buchungslage ja
ja und ja ja ja ja so wir haben jetzt
noch bis zum teil ist es gerade
tatsächlich ist halbzeit
zeilen wie versteht wer hätte es
momentan 204 s klasse ja ich glaube es
wird also um jetzt nichts um ein
bisschen zu steigern also ich bin
wirklich von iron mit einem gold apfel
und
reisen schwert so meine clip gerade
stark aber nicht zu stark in berlin
scheint ich habe jetzt den rest meines
abends in einem in einem ein kart
gefahren hat ein bisschen wetten
deutlich wette mit euch das wirklich
wirklich gestiegen
klassischer dann ja bist direkt da unten
also bei eventim einsätze müssen diesen
rondell das ist bei mir aber ich darf
noch nicht angreifen bis müssen noch
warten
frau spielen bei diesem spiel plötzlich
also bei dem ja bei der schiffschaukel
und so und ich finde einfach keine op
equipment ne ich finde kein erstes nicht
schade röcke und aber so ist das im
spiel gibt es gibt kein mitleid keine
tränchen aus einfach knallhart nachher
knallhart einfach wird derart gefeiert
dann bis zum leben halten konnten ja
auch nichts
neben echten den gold april nur weil du
doch mal bisschen benachteiligung ist
das werk homme lottogewinn für dich kann
zu haben wie man niemand sagen
ich denke mir immer so als wenn einfach
nur jeder mensch zu dir nen euro gibt
den meisten ist bereich sehe ich ganz
cool korrekt aber gibt keine anreize für
die menschen das zu machen
warum auch du könntest echt so einfach
so mal so deine ganzen 15.000 abonnenten
die allemal von eur geben so für den
vertrieb enemy no 1 10.000 euro ist
keine also leute hautnah jetzt machen
die technik in der video schwer
ich hab' ich habe aber echt mal also
stichwort der nächstens kann jetzt kurz
erzählen haben noch 45 sekunden dann
darf keine kissen angerührt werden
ich habe tatsächlich mal meine lieben
versuchen ständig einzurichten vertritt
war dann kurz davor die unten rein zu
packen habe noch im letzten test von
gemacht und was steht da steht einfach
so es punkt mein nachname at meine
universität so vielleicht auch nicht
wenn es wie paypal ist dann wird das amt
angezeigt gläubig oder sonja das mega
ärgerlich eigentlich musst du die
adresse ändern kann es einfacher machen
andere e mail adresse nehmen aber die
die hauptlast lässt sich nicht mehr
ändern soll noch zehn sekunden haben
allerdings zu erfüllen noch ten seconds
to habe ich die dahin nicht mehr nein
vier ich euch wer 21 ok so leute jetzt
geht's ab es wird gefightet gome park
eine map die eine ganz eigenartige
topologie hat also viele berge und
höhlen und und ich wollte schon die
kisten will auch ich darf das nicht wird
es denn jetzt zum zweiten da ich mir
noch ein fisch aus dem wasser ragen
er mache den fisch was habe ich was an
klassische wasser fischen reiten wir
jetzt beenden wie dem magazin will
fighten onsite sobald wir uns sehen geht
es los und es darf mit spielbeginn 63
sekunden erkämpft worden
wir machen die macht es spannend also
sollten wir uns vorher sehen wird auch
toll gekämpft
okay okay okay das ist und es klingelt
an der tür aber ich betrachte habe ich
hier findet es auch schwierig ach weißte
was machen wir falsch
doch es sind der fußball muss die tür
aufmachen so leute wissen wir da es ist
eine grosse deathmatch map die ist sehr
sehr schön hier
ja ich mache gar nicht die scheiße
labern ja man kann halt aufs auge
weggelaufen hier mein mitbewohner hat
gerade eben an der tür geklingelt
bitte denn es ist einer der modelle mit
mir auch germania geboxt habe sagen
lassen ja und er zeigt mir schon den
rücken zu okay wir wachsen ein bisschen
boden
hier mal kurz darauf diesen steinen so
wie ich besser
dann lassen sonst loslegen
charlotte war diese dummen boss perminow
jetzt combo angekommen boden natürlich
meine ich hier führt wo es wärmer hd lp
weil liebe so ja ich habe natürlich dann
mein bekenntnis genutzt und hat mir
schon dass die schweiz aus der mitte
geholt
ja ich mich doch einfach mal in ruhe
machen lassen hätte machen können leute
wenn ihr mehr sehen wollt was passieren
kann wenn man das dem schwert rausholen
will aber die anderen das teilen und
einem rein drücken dann schaut mal beim
dom vorbei der halle kommt dafür den
hals aufgenommen weil logo auch noch
dabei oder sind das ganz ganz ganz
tolles passiert aber ja zu diesem video
und schafft euch gefallen das den daumen
nach oben da wenn es gut findet und
schreibt wie immer
verbesserungsvorschläge die kommentare
wer noch ideen wie man da noch
feintuning vornehmen könnte der dom ist
natürlich der oberste link in der
beschreibung weil mein schatz und ein
video denkt sich auch zeit abgestürzt
sind dann in diesem sinne haut rein